[Music]
that such salud arturo mejía with his
brief informative and it is thursday second of
september after a long debate the
board of directors of the
clark county school district voted to be the
mandatory coronavirus vaccine this
is only for employees and not for
students the board voted 5 to 1 in favor
of the measure that now allows the
superintendent to develop a
vaccine plan for the workforce,
however this does not mean that it will be
mandatory for all of them
public comments against the measure
extended for several hours  And if you still don't
know where to get the coronavirus vaccine,
we'll tell you that there will be
several clinics for the rest of the
week.
there will be a clinic today
inside the airport in terminal
number 1 level 2 starting at one in
the afternoon
and get ready because tonight and  he
good university soccer team opens
its season inside the leader stadium
the rebels face washington
this is the second season with
coach marc who developed all the
action starts from 7 pm
and now a look at the forecast  of the
weather we will have a clear day with
lots of sun however there will be some
smoke again coming from the
wildfires in california the
temperatures will continue to be
below triple digits with a bit of humidity
in the valley and then by the
weekend we will be getting closer to  Los 100
degrees have a nice day health
electro mejía and this was your brief
informative edition in Spanish
[Music]